il y a deux étapes je pense il y a le
fait de rêver de voir la Terre de Haut
de flotter en apesanteur pour pour jouer
moi quand j'étais gamin je rêvais
d'aller dans l'espace par pour bosser
mais après quand on y va c'est parce que
bon c'est pour le travail jusqu'à
l'année dernière c'était que des
professionnels qui vont dans l'espace
pour travailler on a envie de servir la
science la connaissance d'être on a on a
une graine d'explorateur d'aventurier en
fait on devient pas par hasard c'est
d'abord parce qu'on veut c'est combien
de temps le voyage là alors écoutez
c'est entre le décollage et l'arrêt des
moteurs définitifs pour être en orbite
c'est 8 minutes et demi non 8 minutes et
demi on passe de 0 altitude 0 km heure
à 200 250 km d'altitude et deux et 28000
km à l'heure 8 minutes et demi non 8
minutes
donc en fait on traverse l'atmosphère le
plus vite possible c'est pour ça qu'on
part verticalement au bout d'une minute
on a une fois la vitesse du son au bout
de 2 minutes seulement on est à 5 fois
la vitesse du son au-dessus de
l'atmosphère après on inclin la
trajectoire on accélère horizontalement
jusqu'à ce qu'on atteigne ses vitesses
parce que lorsqu'on a cette vitesse de
28 km heure
tout moteur éteint on tombe attiré par
la terre sans jamais la rencontrer on a
la même famille que la courbure de la
terre voilà c'est le principe
c'est incroyable alors il y a pas de
limitation de vitesse j'ai envie de
poser quelques
erreurs il y a pas ouais il y a pas un
gars ouais
[Rires]
29000 km
parfois il y a les débris c'est un des
risques majeurs d'ailleurs de un des
risques majeurs c'est que Anne Hidalgo
débarque dans l'espace
[Applaudissements]
le Sahara oriental et voilà comment on
voit la Terre depuis l'espace et à
l'occasion je passe vous avez remarqué
l'épaisseur de gaz qui constitue notre
atmosphère vu par le côté on se rend
compte que c'est rien du tout c'est
incroyable on se rend compte que la vie
est fragile c'est pas la terre elle nous
survivra c'est nous qui sommes fragiles
alors tu vois l'oiseau est-ce que je
crois qu'il est très sur l'oiseau en
fait
le pris en photo le jour de Noël je
viens de le larguer dans l'espace après
après sa réparation qui s'est déjà fait
larguer dans l'espace
alors je vais vous poser quelques
questions sur vos premières fois dans
l'espace et sur ce que vous avez vous en
avez pensé comment vous les avez vécu
qu'est-ce que ça vous a fait la première
fois que vous avez enfilé votre
combinaison spatiale
alors au début
on le voit un peu comme un ennemi le
vaisseau le scaphandre parce que ils
vont nous exposer à un danger important
mille fois qu'on est bien entraîné qu'on
connaît bien notre matériel notre
combinaison on l'aime allez elle est
lourde la combinaison alors celle qu'on
porte à l'intérieur non c'est juste une
enveloppe étanche d'accord c'est de
l'ordre de la dizaine de kilos celle
qu'on porte à l'extérieur pour sortir
dans le vide c'est plutôt 100 kg quoi
bien sûr quand on s'entraîne dans une
vraie chambre à vide
pour s'habituer à ce scaphandre en fait
il est suspendu par des câbles à des
poulies sinon on se casserait la figure
et on se blesserait grave ça reste 100
kg mais bon on les a pas alors vous
rappeler de votre premier décollage
oui en fait vous savez on parle avec les
anciens qui ont tellement fait ça que on
se fait une idée très très précise et en
fait rien ne m'a surpris pendant le
premier le premier décollage en fait la
première grande surprise qui frappe
c'est dès qu'on arrive près du hublot et
qu'on va pour la première fois la terre
vous étiez à côté hublot
[Applaudissements]
er en fait non j'étais à l'opposé mais
dès que j'ai pu me débrer donc je vous
dis 8 minutes et demi après le décollage
va vers hublot et là c'est waouh et là
on est vraiment
émerveillé et bouleversé c'est c'est un
descriptif il faut le vivre même dans le
film gravity Matt Kowalski joué par
George Clooney c'est merveille comme un
gamin et on l'a tous vécu même si vous
êtes le plus endur si des astronautes
c'est on en a des larmes aux yeux et si
ça va le premier vol on se dit est-ce
qu'on a peur parce que la peur c'est un
sentiment lié à l'inconnu ouais donc si
je vous amène demain dans l'espace vous
avez raison d'avoir peur parce que vous
ne connaissez rien sauf si vous êtes un
casse-cou mais nous quand on part ça
fait des mois qu'on sait que ce jour là
cette heure-là ce sera mon job on
s'entraîne et au moment où ça arrive
c'est normal dans notre vie de le faire
et en fait on est on connaît notre
vaisseau par coeur on a entraîné à
toutes les pannes possibles on passe 70%
de notre temps à nous entraîner à des
combinaisons de panne où on a à la fois
la fuite d'air la fuite de carburant le
feu à bord le court-circuit le mange de
pilotage je répond plus et on s'entraîne
et à la fin on passera en disant quoi
qu'il arrive on s'en sortir
joue cette fait rêver ça tu as envie
d'aller dans l'espace avec moi j'ai
l'impression bon tu sais je le sens j'ai
senti
je suis pas sûr que les gars ont envie
de nous
c'est vrai que la première fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
dans une euh
casse-couilles aux alentours de la terre
non maintenant oui ah ouais c'est vrai
que c'est que dans un milieu fermé hein
pas sortir donc on peut pas sortir ouais
dans les tests de sélection il y a un
test de claustrophobie on nous met dans
un une sorte de de sac qui permet de
diamètre et reconviller non on nous dit
on vous dit pas combien de temps vous
allez rester dedans vous demande juste
de pas vous endormir c'est pour pour
tester la claustrophobie c'est
incroyable ça voilà moi ça c'est ça qui
me gênerait
ça hein mais même si vous êtes
claustrophobe vous approchez du hublot
vous voyez l'immensité de l'univers la
terre et là vous oubliez ça va vraiment
et on peut pas sortir même faire un
petit tour il y a pas des sorts que si
vraiment nécessaire parce qu'on prend un
risque actuel
il y a pas de boutique est-ce que vous
vous souvenez de la première fois que
vous avez dormi dans l'espace
oui en fait le premier vol c'était un
vol au 3/8 on était en deux équipes qui
dormait par exemple travailler et en
fait on avait chacun
une couchette qui ressemblait un peu à
un sarcophage une boîte toute petite
et donc quand on le voit on se dit c'est
vraiment réduit mais quand on flotte
dedans tant qu'on touche pas les parois
on peut avoir l'impression qu'on est
dans une chambre immense et en fait on
dort bien voilà on dort bien mais il
faut attacher son sac de couchage il y
en a qui sont déjà réveillés en dehors
mais maintenant donc c'est ça qui a des
ouvertures pour les bras la tête et moi
j'aimais bien dormir au plafond
j'accrochais mon sac là j'essaie de
faire tout ce qui est impossible à faire
sur terre mais que je peux faire parce
que je suis en apesanteur dans l'espace
je le faisais faire pipi à l'envers
manger à l'envers vivre à l'envers
dormir au plafond pour faire pipi parce
que c'est
c'est un coup à se reprendre à son
entonnoir perso qu'on branle sur le tube
qui va vers le réservoir et il y a un
système d'aspiration ah ouais d'accord
donc stop alors il y a quelqu'un
derrière
c'est bon tout est réglé
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu un truc
vous êtes dit voilà j'ai une petite
frayeur ou jamais jamais est-ce qu'il y
a un truc qui vous est arrivé il y a un
truc voilà un truc qui marchait pas ou
un truc comme ça on a souvent eu des
pannes mais pas grave par contre l'ordre
de mon troisième vol il s'agissait de
réparer le télescope spatial Hubble vous
savez ce télescope qui a de les images
fantastiques et qui est en panne totale
les sorties dans l'espace devaient durer
6 heures maximum moi j'étais pilote du
bras robotique à l'intérieur pour
déplacer mes collègues qui eux étaient à
l'extérieur et au bout de 6 heures il
n'arrive pas à fermer la porte du
télescope qui était gondolé 6h30 7h 7h30
donc là on commence à se dire on est en
train d'entamer les derniers réserves
d'oxygène d'électricité de de système
d'absorption du gaz carbonique donc on
s'inquiète bien sûr et mais on l'a bien
géré on a battu le record absolu de
durée de sortie dans l'espace 8h et 20
minutes alors il y a de quoi à boire
mais il y a pas de quoi manger donc je
peux vous dire avant avant de sortir ils
prennent tous des gros plats de pâtes et
de
c'est incroyable moi je suis fasciné à
part ça j'adore vous avez fait donc
trois missions dans l'espace au cours de
votre carrière vous avez eu donc
l'occasion de vivre 28 jours en tout
dans l'espace trois fois une dizaine des
jours c'était des vols en avait spatiale
que vous avez vu qui sont des vols très
courts très intenses elle n'a pas de
panneaux solaires donc on n'a pas on
peut pas profiter de l'électricité qui
est disponible en continu la Station
spatiale internationale elle est habité
en continu depuis 22 ans elle a jamais
exiger qu'on lui amène de l'énergie
électrique de plus sol elle l'a depuis
par le soleil depuis le début monsieur
alors par contre quand on part très très
loin le soleil n'est plus là il faut des
systèmes radio isotopiques vous savez
les sons de voyageurs
qu'on a lancé il y a 45 ans en 77 les
deux sondes qui ont quitté le système
solaire qui sont à plus de 20 milliards
de kilomètres de la Terre elle marche
encore grâce à ses générateurs radio
isotopiques enfin les ingénieurs étaient
alors que vous êtes un des personnes qui
avaient sélectionné aussi Thomas Pesquet
oui j'étais dans une sélection c'est une
expérience très intéressante qu'il a
vécu lui-même cette année puisqu'il
était dans le jury d'une sélection de
nouveaux astronautes qu'on va annoncer
dans un mois incroyable donc comment ça
se passe ça c'est fou pour tous les gens
qui nous regardent là qui se disent moi
j'ai envie de devenir astronaute toi tu
vas devenir astronaute non t'as pas
envie ça te fait pas rêver
dans l'espace pour le fun ça oui
comme c'est que je veux que ce soit fun
voilà alors la première chose c'est
qu'il faut écouter les informations pour
entendre un appel à candidature d'accord
donc dans les journaux dans la presse à
la radio et vous si vous le sentez que
c'est c'est dans votre dans votre trips
et au fond de vous-même c'est vraiment
le truc qui vous va et que vous avez
vous êtes à peu près en bonne santé faut
pas avoir une santé parfaite mais en
fait très bonne dans certains points
précis c'est à dire lesquels
le côté cardiovasculaire et visuel pour
ceux qui bossent si vous n'avez pas
piloté des machines vous avez pas besoin
d'avoir une voix
mais par exemple l'Agence spatiale
européenne va sélectionner le mois
prochain un parastronaute c'était un
astronaute qui a un handicap d'un pied
ou d'une jambe parce qu'on sert
quasiment pas des gens donc vraiment
c'est des voix c'est des choses très
précises
avec les deux mains et après ça s'étale
sur un an un an et demi ça commence par
les tests qui coûtent le moins cher
parce que ça c'est 10000 personnes qui
candidatent et puis les tests les plus
coûteux on les garde à la fin quand
l'entonnoir a fini par regarder
c'est remplir un dossier d'accord après
un chèque barré
et voilà et donc psychologique de
personnalité des tests psychomoteurs
d'adresse gestuelle des tests
psychotechniques de logiques de de
réflexion de mémoire après il y a des
tests psychologiques de dynamique de
groupe de de
et c'est là qu'on est pour la première
fois face à un jury de personnes de
Dumas dont un astronaute c'est alors là
je vous dis de ce que je sais ici autour
de la table il y en a pas
vous enverrai pas hein
de certains astronautes qui ont marché
même sur la Lune il y en a certains
jamais on aurait pu parier sur eux dans
leur adolescence certains étaient des
des
non médicalement c'est bon alors si vous
êtes professionnel employé par les
gouvernements il y a des il y a des
âges de la retraite d'accord
je suis en pleine santé je suis en
pleine forme
on a mal au fond on a mal de mer c'est
vrai ça ça c'est un problème il y a un
astro sur quatre qui se sent un petit
peu nos hommes mais ça passe très vite
parce que on change le le corps subit
des changements dans le système
musculaire
osseux urinaires digestifs
cardiovasculaires visuel immunitaire
vestibulaire on devient extraterrestre
sur le plan physiologique d'ailleurs
vous amenez un astronaute qui vient de
passer six mois dans l'espace aux
urgences
les examens préliminaires vont laisser
penser au médecin même sans leur dire
d'où il vient qu'il atteint du sida
d'ostéoporose de maladie cardiaque de
troubles de liquide de problèmes visuel
et mes chers
d'une maladie c'est pour ça qu'on
contribue beaucoup à faire avancer la
médecine en prêtant notre corps à toutes
sortes d'expérience oui et en combien de
temps ça redevient terrien le corps
comment en combien de temps vous
réadapter à la tête on s'adapte très
très vite à la pesanteur mais on met
beaucoup plus de temps à se réadapter à
la vie terrestre après avoir le cours
comme on avait spatial ça prend je
dirais une à deux semaines on n'a pas le
droit de conduire pendant quelques jours
parce que le risque d'avoir un accident
est 100% mais après un vol de longue
durée comme le vol de Thomas de Samantha
de qui vient de revenir de six mois
c'est plutôt on se sent normal au bout
de quelques semaines mais les toubibs me
dit tu te sens normal mais t'es pas
encore devenu normal joue pas tout de
suite au squash au tennis pour pas te
déchirer et c'est assez plutôt de moi
quoi
c'est vrai qu'il y a Tom Cruise qui vous
a contacté
oui en fait pour un film il cherchait à
placer une cascade en véritable
apesanteur dans un de ces missions
impossible et puis le scénario de s'y
prêtait jamais donc
il m'a expliqué que quand on lui a
proposé le film qui s'appelle La Momie
dans lequel il y a un avion qui perd le
contrôle et qui se met en chute libre et
là je veux ma scène et nous étions les
seuls à Bordeaux avec notre avion Roger
à proposer de la vraie apesanteur donc
il est venu faire quatre vols avec nous
avec maquillage de l'avion à l'intérieur
et donc je lui ai donné le briefing
alors on m'a dit tu fais en 10 minutes
il était tellement passionné que on l'a
fait sur
voilà on l'a fait sur sur trois quarts
d'heure et il explique en anglais ça
faisait un moment qu'il avait cette idée
en tête parce qu'il aime bien comme vous
savez faire les cascades lui-même il a
parlé que de ça lors des talk shows
Etats-Unis sur ce film et sachez que
tous les bénéfices de ces vols non
scientifiques dans notre avion sont
reversés aux agences spatiales pour
financer la recherche spatiale voilà là
je lui fais le briefing ce sont des vols
en avion
qui recrée la vraie apesanteur en fait
on jette l'avion en l'air par une
manœuvre particulière on reste dans le
domaine de vol et pendant 22 secondes
vous êtes en apesanteur continue comme
dans on met l'avion littéralement sur un
arc orbital et
donc c'est jour l'argent 90% des vols ce
sont des vols pour les scientifiques et
les vols pour les individus ou les
sociétés qui privatisent c'est lors de
six à 7000 euros on s'est calé sur les
prix américain d'accord en fait c'est
que quatre ou six vols par an c'est pas
beaucoup alors et tous les bénéfices se
reversés à la recherche il y a des gens
qui se demandent comment on mange dans
l'espace les questions qui reviennent on
mange dans l'espace
alors en fait on joue avec la nourriture
même si on nous dit quand on est gamin
faut pas jouer avec sa nourriture mais
c'est on mange comme sur terre sauf que
on n'a pas besoin de table tout flotte
et qu'on puisse la nourriture voilà
c'est fort j'ai même amené du fromage de
chèvre fabriqué par ma soeur
mais du foie gras du cassoulet du petit
salé aux lentilles enfin bon on la met
dans une variété de plats
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
que ça n'a jamais eu lieu mais parce que
mais il y a pas de raison que ça marche
pas
si vous n'arrivez pas sur la terre
n'essayez pas
déjà à l'autre parce qu'il y a pas
besoin de matelas de quoi que ce soit
vas-y de ce prophète déjà entraîne-toi
sur la terre Daniel quand tu seras prêt
dans l'espace
parce que tu as démarré tout de suite
franchement tu vas y aller tu vas y
aller
on commence on se lave on se lave on
peut se laver alors en fait à cause de
la pesanteur on peut pas utiliser de
douche c'est trop compliqué ça on a
tenté sur skylave sur mais ça n'a jamais
marché donc on utilise des gants de
toilettes qu'on habite d'un savon
liquide sans rinçage il y a pas besoin
de se rincer je te passe partout et on
se sent pas mal pour toi
et ça marche sur ça marche sur des mois
voilà ça marche très bien non mais c'est
même savon sans rinçage qu'on propose
dans les hôpitaux pour les personnes qui
peuvent pas se déplacer pour mais c'est
fort et franchement moi je suis c'est du
camping la vie à bord c'est du camping
ça ce qu'il faut tout attacher parce que
tout flotte voilà toi tu termines dans
un camping-car tu peux peut-être kiffer
caravane caravane ouais calme-toi et sur
les vols très longs
t'intéresser tout ça ou pas franchement
bah oui
c'est deux heures à 2h30 de sport tous
les jours on est obligatoire arrête
pour pas perdre trop de de calcium dans
les eaux ou trop de muscles donc il faut
être très il faut être prêt quoi bon on
pratique tous les jours ah ouais tous
les jours on fait quoi
chez les Russes ils ont un Rower un
rameur d'accord parce que ça fait du
cardio et sinon côté américain c'est
souvent du vélo du tapis ou de la muscu
où on remplace les poids par des
ressorts parce que les poids en
apesanteur évidemment j'ai déplacé comme
ça entre le poussin index des objets de
200 kg non sans effort
donc on se bat contre des ressorts de
déménager dans l'espace
[Rires]
on a ravitaillé la station mille et on
la transvasé 4 tonnes de matériel à la
main comme ça il y avait des Bretons et
déménageurs
franchement je suis en français je vous
jure on adore vous écouter entretien
avec un astronaute Franck le Hot
Jean-François clervois qui nous raconte
tout franchement c'est un bonheur voilà
je voulais vous le dire et on va suivre
tout ça et continuer parce que c'est
vrai que c'est c'est l'avenir on va pas
se mentir et j'espère qu'un jour on
pourra tous aller dans l'espace on fera
un TPMP dans l'espace un jour et soyez
frères fier de votre agence spatiale le
CNES c'est de l'Agence spatiale
européenne dont on fait partie bien sûr
qui a le record de l'objet posé le plus
loin dans dans l'espace on a posé une
sonde il y a une quinzaine d'années sur
la plus grosse lune de Saturne à 1,4
milliards de kilomètres de la Terre
c'est nous qui a sonniegens c'est une
sorte d'européenne vous avez vous avez
positionné il y a une dizaine d'années
on a posé aussi un petit atterrisseur
sur le noyau d'une comète avec une
précision de du maître à 50 millions de
kilomètres de la Terre quoi
on peut faire des choses incroyables
merci en tout cas Jean-François merci
beaucoup
c'est réglé